have you ever gone in for an audition
where you were so prepared you were so
passionate you gave it your all you know
you nailed it they were you could see
their eyes light up and you didn't get
it and then there's the other where
you're like oh I didn't do very good and
you get it and so it's that weird thing
where being a producer now and being
behind the scenes you realize that there
are so many what's the term politics are
involved as well a lot of times it is
Apple's versus oranges it has nothing to
do with you or your performance there
are so many aspects that's why as an
actor you should just focus on what you
need to do and just be your best because
the politics involved might be that you
weren't right for it you know you could
be in a film with Tom Cruise and you're
just too tall and Tom Cruise doesn't
like to work with you know an actor was
too taller than him even though you were
phenomenal you know and you're like oh I
can I can work shorter you know it's
just there's other issues involved that
don't necessarily have to do with you
and the performance that you you gave
and one thing I learned about
auditioning or I learned to appreciate
which I didn't initially when I was
starting out is that that moment in that
room is yours there's no one directing
you editing you saying anything so it's
kind of like being on stage you have
complete control of that performance in
that moment and when I started seeing
auditions in that way they meant so much
more to me as opposed to you know I know
that we get into that mindset of like ah
why don't they just hire me I
sitting around you know doing the whole
hi yes headshot that whole you know
traditional method of doing business
that you know if you do it constantly it
sort of gets repetitive but that one
moment in the room when you start to do
the performance it's yours and that's
magical so it's kind of like doing
minuscule live performances you know on
a daily basis and it's made me
appreciate auditioning so much more even
though I haven't auditioned for a while
Alex I've been producing mission park
but I do i do enjoy them more so now
you